au cap ferret le mois de mars prend des
airs de saison estivale en raison de la
crise du coronavirus et le confinement
de la population débuté mardi dernier la
presqu'île connaît un afflux de citadins
en villégiature inhabituelle pour cette
période de l'année de nombreux parisiens
ont choisi de rejoindre leur résidence
secondaire ou de louer des maisons dans
la région pour passer au mieux cette
épreuve on s'est dit que c'était mieux
pour notre vie a de tous les jours
devenir comme on a une maison cap ferret
c'est un peu plus facile de vivre ici au
soleil et au bord de la plage que
enfermés dans un appartement à paris
on n'ose pas mettre nos serviette sur la
plage par exemple en part peut-être par
respect aussi par les temps qui courent
pour l'atmosphère et les tensions les
tensions liés à ce virus ne se dire que
mes paires privilégié d'avoir la chance
d'être d'avoir quitté la ville et qu'il
faut pas abuser de voilà de ses
privilèges
un exil qui s'apparentent plus à des
vacances pour certains comme le regrette
le maire du cap ferret dans la presse
locale cette semaine un comportement
contre lequel plusieurs locaux s'insurge
un graffiti anti parisiens même été
aperçu sur les murs d'une résidence
et même si tous les ferret capiens ne
s'oppose pas à l'arrivée massive de
citadins la plupart regrettent
l'attitude dilettante de certains
confiné et un accent en vacances oui
c'est vraiment des vacances fourrure
évoquent ils prennent pas au sérieux
nous on n'a pas grand chose mais bon on
se protège on protège un maximum les
clients comme on peut voilà ce que se
disent aussi qu'autre chose on les
accueille comme des citoyens normaux à
partir du moment où ils respectent les
règles voilà donc mais ils sont chez eux
comme on est chez nous aussi
ils ont des maisons pour limiter les
comportements à risques la municipalité
a ordonné la fermeture des plages ce
jeudi la gendarmerie intervient
également sur le bassin d'arcachon pour
verbaliser toutes les activités
nautiques
quand